you're probably not the first person to
consider taking at least one day of work
to get stuck into Fallout for this week
we haven't seen Dave for days we had to
hold an intervention for Lucy and I'm
getting withdrawal symptoms just doing
this video but you don't have to come up
with some half-baked excuse to give to
your boss you can just use an actual
sick note the VP of PR and marketing at
Bethesda Pete Hines here we can probably
trust as a reputable source has provided
a foolproof doctor's note which can get
you at least a couple of days gaming and
up to a week if you really milk it in
his tweet mindset I figure some of you
might need a note from your doctor for
your upcoming sick days this week so
here you go the note which states that
you need to stay home and rest your
pancreas is signed by Heinz who is
apparently an MD with a PhD and an MBA
and a bring your own cocktail which
probably isn't an internationally
recognised qualification Heinz also
posted a tweet from last year where he
compared launching a game to nearly
falling off a chair the embargo for
Fallout 4 ended today so you've probably
already read all the reviews features
opinion pieces image galleries and
walkthroughs already but don't forget to
check out everything fallout on gamespot
calm and keep an eye out for our
coverage from today with video features
and streams comments if you've managed
to take any days off yourself and what
did your boss say I'm Kate and thanks
for watching